on at booktv.org
and welcome back to book tv's continuing
coverage of the 20th annual national
book festival sponsored by the library
of congress for 20 years book tv has
been a part of the national book
festival when it was held on capitol
hill the national mall the washington
convention center and of course this
year it is virtual but several author
programs are coming up this evening the
full schedule is available on our
website at booktv.org or on your program
guide
some of the authors you'll hear from
include madeleine albright robert gates
salman rushdie and you'll also have the
chance to talk with author rick
perlstein who writes about conservative
politics and as in addition tonight
we're doing a live call-in program with
diamond and silk their book is called
uprising and that's a little later this
evening
so
right now we're going to kick off our
sunday coverage with anne druyan she is
the widow of carl sagan and the
co-author of cosmos here's ms druyan
[Music]
[Music]
hello i'm annie drian
and i'm speaking to you
from my home
in ithaca new york
and
i'm the author of cosmos possible worlds
deeply truly honored
to be participating in an event for the
library of congress
you know in the very first
cosmos
exactly 40 years ago
carl sagan and stephen soder and i
celebrated the great library of
alexandria
and the library of congress means so
very much to me
because of the democratic ideals
of
the world's knowledge belonging to all
of us
and so it's my great honor to be
here i'm here to talk about possible
worlds which is the book i've written
but also
the television series that i
had the pleasure of
producing
writing
and directing
with
my collaborator brandon braga
so
why possible worlds why a third cosmos
after 40 years
the first cosmos
was
an effort
to give the broadest possible public a
global public
its coordinates in space and in time
it was carl sagan's dream
one that i completely share
that
how we found our way in the cosmos
the great story of the 40 000
generations
of human beings
who
in one way or another added to our
current understanding of nature
that we could tell
these wonderful inspiring stories
to a global audience
so that
as many of us as possible could have a
cosmic perspective
on both space and time
and in that original series
there was the cosmic calendar
in which we compressed
what was then thought to be b something
like 18 billion years
of cosmic evolution
compressed into a single year at a
glance calendar
well over the last 40 years
our sense of the age of the cosmos has
changed that is the great strength of
science
it's
power
because it seeks constantly to error
correct to use the methodology of
science five or six very simple rules
to ferret out those things which are not
true
and
that is why science will never be
completed
and it's not for any one generation
to see the whole picture
of space-time
but instead
science is a generation binding
enterprise
connecting all of us
back to our earliest ancestors
and more recently
to the ancient greek inventors of
science
and inventors of libraries
and memory
and even a sense of the future
so the first cosmos was about finding
our place in space time
and the second cosmos
in 2014 cosmosis spacetime odyssey
took some of the
unparalleled
explanatory
power
of some motifs like the cosmic calendar
and the ship of the imagination
a vehicle that can take all of us
anywhere in space time
powered by twin engines
of skepticism
and imagination
that's the key
not one at the expense of the other
rigorous skepticism
uh
a faithfulness
to reality and to what the data
tells us
but at the same time
a soaring imagination
based on what we know
could be possible
so the third cosmos possible worlds
is
my
searching
for a realistic
evidence-based
sense of how we can be hopeful about the
future
we all know
the long shadow
that
falls on our future
who of us looking at our children and
our grandchildren cannot feel a certain
pain
of remorse and concern
about whether or not
we are handing them
a planet
that will be as habitable for them
as it has been for us and our ancestors
i knew
that
there was no need
to
tell the audience
how serious the challenges we face are
but instead
to find hope to find reason for hope
that would be rational
and truthful
and so
i took my inspiration
for the show in the book
from
stories of
some of the scientists
who
across the generations
faced
formidable
and dangerous
enemies who did not want
their information
to be shared with the public
and i
i took a great deal of courage
from the stories of
maybe two dozen people that you'll meet
in the pages of the book and in the
episodes of the show
who against all odds
stood up
in defense of reality
in defense of the evidence in defense of
the methodology of science
for finding out
where we are i mean
nature will not be deceived
you know we can tell ourselves as many
lies as we want to
but in the end
that will get us nowhere in fact it's
worse than that that will doom us
skepticism
this sacred searching of science this is
a selective advantage in fact it may be
the most uh
the most powerful selective advantage we
have
after all as
as uh
organisms we are not
the fastest or the biggest or you know
we don't have those other advantages
what we have
is ability
fantastic abilities of pattern
recognition
and a great cleverness
that can get us
out beyond
that place where the wind from the sun
dies
as our voyager spacecraft
has done
we can rendezvous with a distant planet
or its moon
15 years from now
with
absolute flawless precision
we have these enormous capabilities
and yet here we are
sleepwalking as if in a stupor as if in
a dream
unable to awaken
and to create
the future that we need to create
by making the changes in the way we live
and the way we treat each other
this spring has been
a moment of tremendous
optimism for me
because
i've seen a sea change
in
the united states
not as a result of a single charismatic
leader
but a sea change in the hearts of all of
us
and that's what's so inspiring because
that's what has to happen
and so
i feel a great sense of hope and that
hope
is i hope
completely permeates every page every
word
every shot
in both the series and the book
you know
in possible worlds
we imagine
the distant future
that our descendants
could conceivably
experience
um the worlds that circle other sons
in places that um
we can only dimly apprehend at this
moment with our most powerful telescopes
so how do i dare imagine that future
when
it's 100 degrees fahrenheit at the
arctic
when
our poisoning of the
oceans the rivers
the land
the air
the climate
is so rampant
and
so completely out of control
well
part of it is that
i feel that there is a widespread
yearning
to
fight for the future
and i also feel that
unlike before
we have each other's phone numbers
we're able to communicate with each
other
our planet just at the moment that we
are reaching this urgent and dangerous
rant point in human history
we have developed the means to become an
intercommunicating organism
and to reach people all over the world
i'm so proud of the fact that the
original cosmos series
a personal voyage has been seen by
nearly a billion people
and that both
cosmos the space-time odyssey and cosmos
possible worlds
shown in 180 countries around the world
the message at the heart of cosmos
is to make the case for science
not that science hasn't known sin of
course it has because it's
it's practiced by human beings and we
are fault we are deeply flawed
that's true
but the dangers that we currently face
can only
only be dealt with
with scientific knowledge and a
scientific approach
completely unflinching looking at our
true circumstances whether it be climate
change
or the global pandemic
which has brought us to a halt
these are the days that the earth stood
still
and we before this pandemic began i
don't think any of us thought
that any anything could make us stop in
our tracks
and i personally have been quarantining
alone
from
the first of march
until just a month ago
and for me that was tremendous
experience yes there were moments of
great sadness
great great pain
and yet
i was able to observe
the unfolding of spring
in beautiful ithaca where i live
as never before
to appreciate each new leaf on the trees
and the way that
nature's genius
uh
dwarfs
any fantasy or any
any stories that we can ever
make up
and so
it's left me with a greater conviction
than ever
that we have what it takes
and as you'll see if you read the book
or if you see the show
the book
is
important i think because
you can tell these stories in so in such
greater depth than is possible
in a show
that's on for an hour
but what you'll see in these stories is
not only
the possible worlds the exoplanets the
other worlds
that may lay in our future
as well as
um
the lost worlds of this planet the lost
civilizations of which we know so little
um
waiting to be discovered and unearthed
and finally
it's about the possible world that this
can be that earth can become
if we are resolute if we are unified
if we are clear-eyed
and keep our eye on that most precious
of all prizes
it's beautiful planet
so completely graced by life in almost
every conceivable
tiny nook and granny
great diversity of life
that is so precious
if we can value this world
and the
way that it sustains us
and our fellow earthlings
above
money
if we can
value it above a certain inconvenience
if we can value the air
the water
the climate the things that we need to
survive as an organism
above those other things that are just
recent constructs
of only the last few centuries if we can
keep our eye on this most precious of
all prizes
then
the wonders that await us
in this cosmos vast and ancient
are
beyond our wildest imagination
you know science has done some things to
us that many people feel very hurt by
and i respect that and understand that
we started out we started out in 1609
just to
go back to galileo
you know we
we a lot of us
cherish the idea
that we were the only children
of a creator
that the entire universe revolved around
us
and
one by one what i call the great
emotions of science
one by one well
you know once the world had
accepted to the extent that we have
uh the the work of the earlier scientist
copernicus who said
that the sun was at the center of the
solar system
once we said okay we're not at the
center of the solar system but
we're at the center of the galaxy
we're the center of the universe
no
no no not any of those well we were
created separately from the rest of all
the other living beings on this planet
we are god's only children
well no it turns out that we are so
deeply related to each other and to all
of the life that we share this planet
with
that we have more in common genetically
you and me
with a sunflower
than we are likely to have
with a being from any
other world in the cosmos
and so i
cherish what carl sagan said
if a person disagrees with you
let them live
you will not find another in a hundred
billion galaxies
and so that's these are some of the
values of science that image of the pale
blue dot
you know to me when i look at that and i
looked at it countless times
since that first moment that carl showed
it to me
back in the early 90s
when i look at that image
i say
this is where
science
and spirituality
and
emotions
and even aesthetics
meet in one place you do not need an
advanced degree
to understand what that pale blue dot is
telling you
it's saying
that we inhabit a tiny dot
how
how can the nationalists
the chauvinist
the polluter
the purveyor
of the fossil fuels and other products
that will destroy our future
how can they look at that dot
and escape its meaning
and so you know there's always been
a kind of wall
a very tall wall
between
science
and the rest of us
and i
i was not
born inside those walls of science
i was a lousy student
i was not a good math student or a
science student and i didn't come to my
love of science
until
until i was an adult until i found those
pre-socratic philosophers and began to
feel included and then when i met carl
sagan
in my view
one of the greatest teachers
of the last thousand years or more
when i met carl sagan and
had the honor
and privilege
to spend
20 years
thinking with him
writing with him working with him
building our beautiful family together
i
felt this
overwhelming desire
to share
the spiritual uplift the joy the
pleasure
of knowing even a little bit
about
the universe revealed by science with
everyone on earth
as carl used to say when he was asked
why he didn't spend all his time in the
laboratory why did he go on these
television shows and
go to
immigration and naturalization
ceremonies and
kindergartens and
so many other things that he did to talk
about science
he would say when you're in love
you want to tell the world
and that's how i feel about my book
which is very personal in many ways and
of course personal in ways that the
television show could not be
um
i felt
really that's what i wanted to do was to
share this knowledge
which was no longer impenetrable to me
which was no longer boring
which was no longer
something that i felt
alienated from but instead
i felt an almost evangelical desire
to tell these stories of these great
scientists these heroic figures
people who chose death rather than
telling a lie about science
i don't think i could do that
you know i mean these are people
who you've never heard of they're not
the darwins or the galileos they're not
the household names
but instead they are
unsung heroes
who
who lived so bravely so dramatically
and who made it possible for us to
venture to the stars
i've never known anyone
who was able to
integrate
both a very rigorous
uh evidence-based
mathematical
uh
knowledge of physics and chemistry
and biology
that was comprehensive i was able to
integrate
that
very rigorous
skepticism
with
a boundless imagination and sense of
wonder and joy
you know it's always
the
the founding myth of our
civilization is that if you partake
of the fruit
of the tree of knowledge
you will be
ruined
and miserable and doomed and it's a
criminal thing to do
whereas
i feel that in the story of genesis when
we do partake
of the fruit of the tree of knowledge
that's when we become our human selves
it's the most natural thing for us this
is what we're really good at
and so
you can't you can't do it just with
skepticism
and
you know i'm not the first person to say
this uh einstein carl many people have
said this
way before me
but you can't you know you need that
kind of
you need
that baloney detection kit in your brain
which
helps you discern
things that are real from things that we
want to be real but are not
so you need that
but then you also need
imagination and a sense of the great
beauty of life
and
when i think of the person who was able
to integrate those two things
perfectly never one at the expense of
the other i always think of carl
and uh because he embodied that
you know he he followed his bliss
and uh and i think was probably one of
the most fully realized human beings
well he was the most fully realized
human being that i ever met
because he never lost his sense of the
great joy of life
the romance of life
the romance of being alive
in the cosmos i think one of the reasons
he's so beloved
is he had that very urgent sense
that the universe was
we now think it was 13.8 billion years
old
but
the universe let's say is 13.8 billion
years old
how long do we live we are mayflies a
hundred years is the best we can get
and yet carl knew
and he internalized it it wasn't just
lip service it wasn't just something he
preached
he knew
how brief life is
and so
he lived it with that sense of great
pleasure and appreciation for even the
smallest things but at the same time
dreaming so big
dreaming
of what it would be like
to stand
on
the world of another son
to travel into the very distant future
or into the past
and so
i i felt i feel like
something's happened
since we began
space exploration
before the space age began and i read
about this in the book and we actually
tell this story in the show
before the space age began all of the
different scientific disciplines were
very siloed
so there was
not a single journal
on planet earth
where a
biologist and a geologist could
co-author
a peer-reviewed scientific paper isn't
that amazing
and in the beginning of carl's career
even when i came into his life he was
constantly
criticized for being wildly
interdisciplinary
and yet i think he understood
that
once you leave this planet whether
you're sending your instruments
or other human beings
there's no way to explore and to
understand
without a complete synthesis of many
different scientific
disciplines you know what you can't go
to mars
without a geologist
and you want an astronomer you want a
chemist you want a physicist and you
probably want an astrobiologist if
you're going to
hunt for past mars life if there is any
and so he was part of that generation
and in fact he edited the very first
scientific journal icarus
which
made it possible
for a collaboration
among the scientific disciplines
and that's another facet of you know i
always think of him as the great
tear down of walls
not just the wall between science and
the rest of us but also the walls
between the disciplines
and done with such good humor and joy
and imagination
of
what the next experiment
on the next spacecraft would be
but also
how to enthrall
people of all ages
with the
joy
of discovery
there need not be you you need not
sacrifice
your humanity
and your soul
to be a scientist
and
if you're a writer an artist
a musician
you need not
lose any of that creative juice
by knowing
something about nature in fact i think
it makes
everything we do that much richer
[Music]
you